facing bets as we speak this is going to
take your brand to a whole new level i
think there's been some sort of
confusion i like your spike face they're
my guts
i love it i'm looking for my sister
wrestler in the back wrecked absolutely
wrecked
dear lord
that's oh
that's fake mandarin's jew
nice one
the last thing i do
is would be any of this
i would literally pull every muscle in
my body doing this
um
and step on their back and they fall wow
that's a dead man killed oh my god dear
lord dear lord bro oh my lord oh my lord
i have a really bad fear of heights
that's how you die welcome back to new
rock stars shangji and the legends of
the 10 rings has finally arrived in
theaters thank the lord jesus i love
this boy and with this new entry into
the mcu catalog we get a new hero and
some new villains and a return of a few
old heroes and villains and new forms of
magic dragons cute little faceless
chicken pigs with no like literally it
looks like a walking butt i love it and
on top of that some of the best fight
sequences that we've ever seen in the
mcu period this is inside marvel hour
after show for marvel's latest cinematic
release sean chi and the legend of the
10 rings my name is mt and we're going
to talk about some of the biggest
revelations and burning questions left
over from this magnificent film and of
course i'm here today with my fellow
chongqi lover jessica clemens what's
going on juice ah the faceless chicken
butts
i was morris they write those things
into scripts for me to buy it i don't
i was like these are for kids this is
for a grown 27 year old woman i freaked
out
i'm obsessed with it the movie was great
the choreography was amazing i am so
excited for every single person in this
movie i can't wait to see what we're
going to keep doing with them and i'm
sorry we just need to get right
right oh my god the build-a-bear release
the morris build-a-bear right now me too
oh i need something to cuddle with all
right but anyway let's do a quick plot
summary because for 1 000 years
has been gaining power and influence
through the use of his 10 rings criminal
organization and is mystically powered
10 rings who the organization is named
after and that is until he gets beat up
on his first date in the woods and falls
in love with a powerful fighter named
zhang li from the mythical city of
tallow
that's how i met my ex not a great way
to meet your ex
with violence not a great way to start a
relationship gotta say when woo puts his
rings in a box and stops being a crime
boss in exchange for being a dutiful
husband and father to shang chi and jai
ling because that's what you gotta do
don't be a dead be dead and after his
love dies which is very sad it'll really
really sad part of the movie when who
puts the rings back on and gets back to
business because people gotta die okay
just gotta say that if someone kills my
wife they're gonna die too anyway he
starts training his son to be an
assassin and won't let his daughter play
killer so you know she decides to learn
on her own because she's a strong
independent woman and we're all about
that and when he's ordered to perform
his first assassination at the age of 14
he runs away with no plan to ever return
so you know that's some brutal [ __ ]
fourteen really rightfully so hard age
two you're going through puberty um
heart age too you gotta kill your first
person and also go through puberty but
this brings us to present day san
francisco where shang chi who now goes
by sean works as a valet with his best
friend katie she doesn't know anything
about his true past until they're
ambushed on a bus by some thug sent by
wen wu and led by razorfist the target
was a pendant worn by shang chi and he's
on a mission to warn his sister who has
a matching set chengchi and katie arrive
in macau where they discover an
underground live streaming fight club on
the top floors of an abandoned building
chung chi winds up fighting and losing
to his sister xiao ling who it turns out
is running the whole thing death dealer
shows up with more wenwoo's men and
brings sheng chi zhao ling and katie
back to one who's 10 rings compound it's
here we learned that when we was
planning to find the hidden tao low
village now that he has the map thanks
his kids matching pendants he falsely
believes zhang li is trapped behind a
gate in tao lo and his wife is calling
for his help so sad literally so
little sidebar this is great following
the doctor strange episode of what if
because it's like heartbreak does make a
villain heartbreak can easily make a
villain we see it here and that's the
emotional connection i needed to this
movie oh that's a great connection i
love that connection but yes shenshi
wants to warn the people of tallow of
what's coming their way because he's a
nice boy and after running into trevor
slattery from iron man 3 and his chicken
pig morris
the mvp the hero of the film he now has
to get away to get there in intello we
meet shang chi's aunt and prepare for
wenwu's arrival because he's about to do
a lot of murder and killing and chongqi
confesses that he did commit the
assassination his father ordered ooh and
he clearly regrets it when will his army
arrive and some soul suckers get loose
from the mystical gates and the great
protector is awoken from her aquatic
slumber to help fight off the mega soul
sucker and shang chi is able to channel
the magic of talo and use the ten rings
to finally defeat the mega soul sucker
oh once and for all because you know
souls are supposed to be in the body and
chunky and katie returning their life in
san francisco only to be subtly summoned
by wong via sling ring then we get the
mid-credit scene where we learn that
wang bruce banner and captain marvel
have no idea what these rings are or
where they come from but they do learn
that the rings are calling out to
somewhere someone somewhere out there
like it's just a beacon for something
and then of course the post credits
scene xialing was supposed to break up
the ten rings organization but it turns
out she wants to run the whole thing who
could have saw that coming
yeah
we're gonna get into this
uh
it's literally that's screaming i'm
hollering well this should have been
like a three-part inside marble we have
to of course remind you that our merch
partners at epic hero shop just dropped
a shirt inspired by chongqi the shirt
has a really cool design that will
empower you to walk into any room with
big warrior energy and this is the
eighth design in the latest obsession
line of collectible shirts by new rock
stars and each shirt design is selected
by the new rockstars team to celebrate
what we're obsessing over right now and
on the collar is a numbered shirt label
to identify the collectible shirt as
unique in this exclusive series and this
is now issue number eight and once the
shirt goes off the stock that number
will be forever retired from the latest
obsession lineup so check out all the
awesome gear in apparel including the
shanxi latest obsession shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com but before we
continue we also want to thank
skillshare for sponsoring this video
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for curious creative folks and
skillshare lets you explore new skills
deepen existing passions and just get
lost in creativity skillshare offers
classes designed for real life learn and
grow with short classes that fit any
schedule and each class is a combination
of video lessons and a class project and
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning that there are no ads and there
are always launching new premium classes
so that you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you they
have classes and topics new rockstars
fans will absolutely enjoy like
animation film music and freelancing one
of their classes that look super dope is
productivity for creatives build a
system that brings out your best by
thomas frank he's a prolific musician
and content creator and his class goes
over stuff like how to set up your
physical and digital space to work for
you not against you i definitely need
that i i seriously do like it's
just a mess i said save me thomas frank
the first 1000 of our subscribers to
click the link in the description will
get a month free trial of skillshare so
that you can start exploring your
creativity today do it skillshare learn
something so jess hit me with that first
question okay what was the mega soul
sucker and where the hell did it come
from everyone said now we all need to go
the mega soul sucker that's a good
question that's my nickname
we've now met another realm destroying
monster that katie calls the mega soul
sucker but what is this thing anyway we
do learn that through some wooden
tableau exposition that the people of
tallow call this beast the dweller in
darkness and when i heard this i was
freaking out because like that is the
deepest cut of all time i didn't think
they would i would ever see the dweller
in darkness in the mcu because in the
comics the dweller in darkness is one of
the fear lords which are a group of
demons who gain all their power from the
fear of others and they were first
introduced in some doctor strange comics
in the early 90s which was a very dark
time in comics the dwelling darkness has
been depicted in the comics with
tentacles coming out of his face similar
to the character of cthulhu and in the
film the dweller and darkness has
tentacles and so do all of his flying
minions because this is the tentacle
phase of the mcu it was the infinity
saga now we're in the tentacle saga
kevin talked to me last night he called
me and he told me this but does this
creature have anything to do with the
other tentacled monster that we've seen
in recent episodes of what if and what
realm did it come from and does it have
anything to do with the rumored
appearance of shuma gorath in the
upcoming doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and like what is
with marvel's in their tentacle monsters
lately like i just i knew this was
coming i knew the day for tentacles was
coming and i feel like everyone should
have saw this coming as well i would
really like to have a tentacle so
while watching the movie i was like
there's so many connections to different
movies and what we're watching currently
then i'm like which one is more like set
in stone i would love to think that this
has this creature has something to do
with the same world that we're seeing
the tentacle monster and what if but i
still don't think
this one is going to be as connected to
doctor strange as what we just saw
because the dwelling in darkness is from
the doctor strange comics so it's like
i think they're in two different realms
i think they're in two different realms
um but if they are in the same realm i'm
my bad
i'm gonna i'm gonna say something
differently and i think that i think
that they are they might not be the same
type of beast but i think that they are
sort of like you know either cousins or
neighbors from the same realm of like
you know the realm in between like the
the world in between dimensions is where
i feel like these squid monsters are
coming from when i saw the movie in
theaters i was like what if this is in
the same realm of where because in the
comics we get lumira or i can't i can't
remember the maria maria thank you from
the comics for the deviants but what if
in the serie like in the mcu they're
coming from all different planes they're
not just coming from underwater what if
this is another portal to where the
deviants are and this is our version of
the deviants in the internal trailer
those deviants look very dragon like
these creatures don't look like they're
they're creatures they're like they're
they're straight creatures in the comics
we're seeing them still like able to
converse and talk but this one these are
just monsters so that's why i was like
this is giving the same vibe as the
monster we saw in shanghai i feel like
there's some type of relation between
these monsters and the what-if monsters
but also the monster from guardians of
the galaxy vol 2. oh yes yes yes yes yes
yes if you if you look at if you
re-watch
like the the
sucking the soul sucking is there's
these rainbow colors coming out of it
and when the monster comes out in
guardians 2 there's all these rainbow
mists and all this stuff and he's going
for that energy source that scene in
guardians of the galaxy 2 was marvel and
kevin feige's way of getting us prepared
for the next phase of interdimensional
and eventually because like you know
we're getting introduced to these
mythological and like these demony type
things
i think you know i know that you know
saying the m word is very uh you know
dicey stuff but i think this is kevin
feige's way of eventually getting us to
a mephisto scenario down the line i'm
not saying it's coming right away but
like
i was holding on to it yeah oh yeah the
concept of using like these demonic
perceived creatures and and making them
interdimensional creatures seems like a
very uh scientifically based thing that
to make the whole mcu feel real rather
than just being like oh yeah it's just
dragons dragons are really yeah it's
that makes sense that makes sense but i
get that but i'm here all right jess i
got a question for you are wong in
abomination working together and what
was that location that they were
traveling back to through the sling ring
portal and like why were they even
fighting in the first place okay so i
honestly because we're following the
doctor strange trailer we obviously
think that's where wong was going
wong said it's winter time i'm angry at
you i need to get my anger out somehow
so i think he does safari match with
abomination that's not wang's first time
being there wong gets his anger out in
this way he's a peaceful person he's
meant to be peaceful but working with
doctor strange and seeing him in that
trailer he's so tired of him that this
is the way that he gets his anger out is
by doing this and i think him an
abomination they're not necessarily
working together but i think they're
acquaintances and friends last time we
saw abomination he was locked up right
he got like taken away so is he getting
where do you think they are because i
was immediately like are is he taking
him back to his jail cell
i think that's exactly what's going on
here because abomination is in the raft
this entire time abomination has been
like you see the way uh either through
shield and then like brought to the raft
eventually but like i think that that's
where wang is bringing him straight back
to maxell and like him fighting is sort
of him like is like recti like this
maybe this is like their way of showing
us that abomination is getting some type
of you know therapy and like some type
of help so that when val comes to him
it's like hey i'm forming a team
together he's not this like oh he's a
murder monster why would you freaking
approach him it's like oh no he's you
know he's better he knows how to work
with people so like now he can't be a
part of this thunderbolt or whatever
val's doing and i think that's the
perfect segue for him showing up in
she-hulk so that's why i'm like we need
this to confirm that he's not what we
saw in 2008
and bring him into she-hulk so i think
that's what it completely is i don't
think they're like he's not going to be
in doctor strange to helping wong i
think it was just like this is a tad bit
we saw abomination he's
completely fine there we're going to see
him in she-hulk and we're gonna see him
down the line more so we do see bruce
banner at the end of this movie and like
we see him that he's in like a sling
like a like on arm sling so like do you
think that wong could have been doing
bruce a solid and be like hey man i know
that you usually are the one to fight
this man just for fun but like i'll take
him out because you hurt i'll take him
out we'll have a good time i think his
arm is in the sling just from when we
last saw him from the snap and i think
he's just better at changing back
because it's been a couple of years he
definitely has become in tuned with his
inner self and has been unable to change
himself back and forth now probably but
i would love the idea in the theory that
he's like hey man tag me in
tag me and let me get up in there i will
beat his ass
i want to think that wong has bloodlust
from uh his fight with uh what's it
black obsidian or black dwarf i forget
which one in avengers infinity war he's
like i took him down i took his arm off
so like i could just fight all the big
monsters because that's what i do
because i'm wrong that
just wong needs to get that energy out
and i i stand by it steven is being
stupid half the time now and you are
just done with it you got it up to here
you need to get your anger out in some
way go fight honestly that's entirely
rational like yeah that's what i would
do i'd be like you know what stephen
you're so arrogant and annoying i need
to punch something bigger than myself
okay so we're on to the third one where
did the rings come from what tech
powered the weapons of the ten rings
have we seen it before and why did the
ring set off the alarm bells at
camartage now and not before that is the
big question so can i say something yeah
go for it
so if you guys have read the comics if
you guys read the comics so
what what issue is it it's like the it's
the iron man i always call them by their
numbers i'm sorry but you guys look it
up it's iron man issue 50 where we see
the mandarin for the first time and then
it is revealed that um with later issues
that he basically found these 10 rings
in a ship
and took him and he took him
and i love that but also there's so much
behind it like how the maculans were the
ones driving the ship and the maculan is
now just a skeleton dragon and he was
just like i'm going to take this these
rings that powered this ship if we're
going with that original theory that the
rings came from a maculan ship that's
there
and i think that's a good one to always
go by but then there's also the matt
fraction comic books where he basically
killed someone and stole the rings from
them and they were immaculate that was
trying to like that was needing help i
don't know if we're gonna live by those
two comic book theories though because
in the movie they just said it was like
the oldest rings of all time
there's some old ass rings
oh god stop do you think we're gonna go
with the comic books original origins or
you think they're gonna make a
completely new origin because the matt
fraction one is a little racy with him
being like the child of a prostitute
that got murdered and then he had to
kill the pimp and then we have the
originals stan lean ones which are
really offensive i i like the how you
brought up the the mcluhan's and uh
for those of you who don't know uh the
mcluhan's are this uh where the you know
fing fang fume all these dragon type
beings in the comics they're presented
as this like alien race of like dragon
type people and so the ten rings in the
comics come from this mcluhan race and
that and the mandarin finds it he kills
the person that originally had it and
then he wears it as rings and uh so yeah
so when you bring up the mcluhan's these
rings could easily be a beacon
contacting these mcluhan races like
because that's why i think where you're
going with that um yeah and like we we
could be getting more interdimensional
threats because of these rates because
when when will raise the rings he's
receiving a signal from the dweller in
darkness but when sheng chi uses the
rings he's pushing out
so like there's a difference between
push and pull here with these rings with
this beacon being sent out we're
probably going to get you know
interdependent the the same multiversal
interdimensional threats that the
ancient one was like hey man uh if you
knew all these threats you would run
away in terror and like at the end of um
duck strange one uh wong says that with
the death of the ancient one everyone's
gonna hear about it and like they're
going to come everybody from different
dimensions are going to hear about it
and come to our dimension so this could
just be that happening the beacon's
coming out um and the interdimensional
are coming to the mcu much like the
alien threats came to marvel earth after
the tesseract was used i need to put
these scissors down
because
yes you guys and that's the part that
it's like this is what i was freaking
out about with the post edit scene or
the post credit scene i was like they're
coming because even if they were like
you know what we're not going to let
them come we're not going to let them
come if we were going off our own
theories that we could theorize that
this could be a beacon to the celestials
like this could be a beacon to all of
them and being like hey
you guys need to show up now
like it's time like this
what we're opening the door to right now
is so important and so good
and i
can't wait for dragon people
to show up seriously like this is
opening up a huge pandora's box of just
oh cool ass [ __ ] creatures this
movie's just so good it's so good i
can't wait for uh what it's what's
coming we do see at the end of the movie
that hulk is back in his banner form so
like why is that so because in the
avengers end game he was like me and
bruce i mean me and the hulk we we
worked it out but nick now he's fully
bruised so like do you think that him
and hulk are not good anymore i really
want to believe by now he's become
better at like making sure
hulk comes out and bruce stays in and
like doing those things especially after
end game i'm more worried about that arm
in that sling because it seems like he
can never use it again
yeah he seems pretty hurt or like maybe
shonchi just happens really
like really after everything like just
still um healing up i think it'd be more
fun if like the snap just really messed
up hulk and now he's just like you know
they just lost control again because
like i love
the pure hulk like professor milk is
good but like pure like brute like oh
i wanna punch everything hulk is where
it's at yeah yeah
i think that that's like teasing like
that sort of returned uh uh original
recipe hulk but final question of the
day let's talk about our boy trevor
slattery because
we haven't seen him since iron man 3 and
ben kingsley knows how to
just pull in a performance does trevor
slattery go back to jail at the end of
this or does he live out his days as the
head of the talo community theater as he
should because i definitely think he
stays there because he doesn't want to
be in prison and they're probably like
yeah my dad's dead and the compound's
gone so i guess you can stay here
and maybe he is doing that i also think
that like morris wouldn't be able to
like survive without him now and i'm
like this is true they are now one unit
that scene was also so so funny when
that faceless chicken pig came out and
he was like oh thank god you can see him
too he was like oh i thought i was going
crazy oh thank the lord oh my god we
always need a comic relief we always
need a comic relief and this was the
perfect one like and how long was he in
prison anyway like how long did we have
him because
all uh was it the all hail the king
short like that was from like what 2013.
that's what i was like 20 23 22 like 25
i was 10 years i was literally like
you've been in there for like 10 or 15
years
like i wonder if he got blipped too like
i wonder oh
i doubt it knowing him his luck his luck
he did not get pulled honestly like if
i'm in prison and i got blitz i'd be
like oh thank god phew
he just stayed in there not eating
if he got blipped i hope morris went too
either they both go or none of them go
that's that's all i want to say but that
is it for this special episode of inside
marvel and do not forget to check out
our many merch options at new
rochestermerch.com because these shirts
are going fast you got to get them you
got to get them i can literally get
compliments on my shirt all the time
please you can follow me mastertainment
you can follow jessica clemens at lulu
underscore clemens and follow new
rockstars on social media platforms
because that's where tyler does all of
his magic oh so good but after you do
all that of course make sure to hit that
notification bell on youtube so you can
get notifications every time we upload a
video and subscribe to inside marvel
wherever you get your podcast and thank
you all for watching we love you all
goodbye chungchi is the best i love me
some faceless mythical creatures i love
a faceless mythical creature pig
foreign